Katy Perry tears up while paying tribute  to the victims of the Manchester attack  it's awful it's awful it's awful  Perry was visibly emotional while  performing in London on Thursday a city  not too far from Manchester where 22  victims died Monday after a bombing  outside in ariana grande concert it was  hard for me because we all loved music  we're all listening to the same music  you know and you think about it and you  think that's fact that's my friend  that's my sister that's my brother  that's my cousin that's the person that  loves music you know the singer  encouraged fans in the audience to stand  strong what you should do is not let  them win they can never take that part  away from us ever  [Music]  [Applause]  before performing yes part of me  Perry led the crowd in a moment of  silence